what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time
i'm not going through any of the intro
we're getting straight to business today
block five is a sponsor go to
blockfy.com
pomp you can earn up to 8.6 apy in an
interest bearing account go to
blockfy.com
one topic and one topic only go
this is madness this is absolute madness
this is the most un-american thing i've
ever seen
we are watching rich hedge funds
billionaires and financial institutions
absolutely hijack the financial system
these idiots have played with people's
livelihood and wealth for decades
they have taken advantage of the little
guy
the little guy who didn't have access to
markets who didn't have access to
information
who didn't have communication tools and
now
all of a sudden when the friction and
all of that goes away and the average
little investor the bottom 45 percent
don't have investable assets they're
preyed upon
but now all of a sudden we start to give
those people information
communication tools and access to
markets
and they start pushing back and now the
rich
hedge funds the billionaires and all
those people
all the capitalists all the free market
enthusiasts
they start crying foul and they start
losing money
this isn't capitalism this isn't free
markets
this is absolute madness
and the fact that the very platforms
discord robin hood and others who hung
their hat
and pretended to be the rebels the
pirates of the entire thing
that they were gonna empower the little
guy that the second
any pressure is applied they literally
stop
trading stocks or they kick off these
communities from their platforms
it's disgusting and every single kid
with a keyboard and internet connection
right now
is pissed off they're watching and i do
not think
that wall street or the establishment
understands
the revolution that is happening right
now
you no longer have to be wealthy
in this country we have used wealth as a
proxy for intelligence
for way too long it's
[ __ ] that's all it is that's exactly
what it is
we say oh if you're rich you must be
smart
no retail was right about bitcoin retail
was right about tesla
retail was right about gamestop retail
is smarter than you think and what we
are watching
is we are watching hedge funds and
financial institutions
be exposed it's not because they're
smarter
it's because they've constructed a
system that allows them to
profit on the back of the little guy
but now the little guys got tools and
the little guys got their
own army to fight back and what they
just did
to hedge funds is they just punch them
square in the nose
but if these hedge funds really believe
they're so smart if you really think
you're so good
come meet us come meet us in the market
where it is free where's unmanipulated
where there is
no bailouts there's no circuit breakers
it's just
if you're right you profit and if you're
wrong you lose money
come meet us in the decentralized world
because that is where every single one
of these retail investors are gonna go
they're not gonna keep playing the rig
to game they're gonna move
to the decentralized world where you
can't shut the market off it trades 24 7
365 i don't care if you're tired or not
the market's trading
i don't care if you want to go to dinner
the market's trading
24 7 365 doesn't matter where you were
born what language you speak what your
education level is how rich you are how
smart or dumb you are
if you got an internet connection you're
in the game and what we are about to
witness
is a complete revolution of these
markets
these assets and all of these geniuses
who went to harvard and wharton they
wear their suits and ties
and they act like they've got some kind
of sophistication
or some level of superiority to the
average guy
roaring kitty and deep value on reddit
just blew up your hedge fund and they're
not even trying yet
and so now what you have is you've got
millions of people around the world
that are all going to work together
they're going to invest their capital
they're going to allow their ideas to be
tested
in a war of attrition of ideas on the
internet
and what we're going to get is a more
efficient market we're going to get
better educated investors
and it's going to expose the
establishment for exactly what it is
it's a racket we've known it's a racket
for decades
we just didn't have the tools to fight
back but now people have the tools
and what we are going to see is complete
decentralization
of everything beautifully said
i'm pissed go ahead what do you think
i feel like you're more relaxed thank
you for asking i thought you'd never ask
um so i think watching this from
the sideline um back when
occupy wall street was happening it got
a lot of press it got a lot
a lot of attention but at the end of the
day those were people who were
protesting
a system that did not care they knew it
would eventually go away they knew the
protests would eventually go away they
didn't there was no
financial hurt that they experienced now
they're the the same people are armed
with information the internet
and money access to capital and access
to the markets
so now they're actually making the
people they were protesting back then
they're making them hurt and they're
making them they're taking
money from them and now they are forced
to pay attention
because it's actually affecting them
they're not just in a park somewhere
in a physical location i completely
agree
the worst part about this on top of the
fact that
the people are taking money right now
they're actually delivering
billions of dollars of losses but
also we have to remember that when those
people left zuccotti park
what has happened over the last 10 years
is the federal reserve and elected
officials have devalued the dollar
and they've continued to punish that 45
percent of americans
who own no investable assets but those
people now
are getting in the game and what we're
realizing
is that the crowd is more powerful than
any one institution
of course and you can't discount them
the uh one of my favorite memes that i
saw on twitter it was not about this it
was something else
but it said um everyone's always
screaming like let the market decide let
the market decide and then it says
market
decides and then those same people are
like oh no that was wrong that was wrong
and it's like well if you want to talk
about the free market
let it decide it has decided this is
this is what people are doing
you can't argue with it right of course
again
what they want is they want a rigged
game i want a free market when i'm
making money
but when i start losing money shut it
off shut it off
it's kind of like when we play uh chess
and you quit
exactly that's exactly what it's like
this is absolutely absurd there are
people
who want to take their hard-earned money
and they want to invest it who cares how
they want to invest it
let them decide what they want to do
with their own money
you've already kept them from the
private markets by saying if you're not
rich you can't participate
because of the accreditation laws get
rid of them
let everybody play in every game
it is your american right to make money
or lose money who cares if they make
money or lose money
they're grown-ups they can make their
own decisions with their own money
the government ain't gonna save them and
neither is anybody else
this whole idea of where protecting the
little guy is
garbage the little guy is out and about
they don't need that protection they got
their own protection
the little guy literally on forums on
the internet
realized that a hedge fund was
selling a stock more than a hundred
percent short
and they short squeezed them sounds like
a little guy
is perfectly capable of managing their
own money
there's not too many people who are
yelling and screaming
at the hedge fund who have ever turned
fifty thousand dollars into ten plus
million dollars can i ask how this has
never happened before i mean
it has oh it has it has it's just never
been with this much
much momentum and attention scale yeah
right and and then guess what they did
and then they went from one to the next
to the next to the next
and they're gonna keep doing it but i
promise you what we are going to see is
people are going to leave this
centralized rigged system
and they're going to move to that
decentralized world in the decentralized
world there are no bailouts there are no
circuit breakers there are no hours of
operations
it is fully global if you are the best
you will profit if you're wrong you will
lose and
if these people on wall street think
they're so great come meet us in the
decentralized world
because there ain't no way that they're
going to be able to survive fighting
intellectually with millions of people
around the world
that's all i got okay and i got one ask
lm question on this very topic daniel
weller asks how is it legal to sell
short more than a hundred percent of a
company's floated shares
i read that too and basically the idea
is that they're counting
on the fact that the stock will go so
low that they'll be able to buy
more right like that's the that's why
they have more than 100 percent
in a generalized manner i don't want to
get into all of the details and frankly
there's
a ton of nuance it depends on how much
leverage is used who are you borrowing
from what the stock price it like
there's a lot that goes into it the
point of this question
is that they shouldn't be allowed to do
it that's the point
they should not be allowed to do that
and what happened is
when they did it they exposed themselves
to more risk
and they got caught as my father would
say
to people like this be a man sit there
and take the losses on the chin
you took the risk now take the losses
stop
right running and screaming and crying
like a little
baby to the market saying shut it off
shut it off shut it off
no you took the risk now take the loss
because if you took the risk and you
could profit you'd take the profits
but that's the problem is we got a bunch
of capitalists
on wall street who are really just
socialist
they just want to make sure they just
want to make sure
that they play a game where they can
always win that's not how the world
works
and that's not what the people's will is
and the people
are showing you that they're not going
to play this game anymore
so good luck woohoo people see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends